how's it going everybody we got a really
cool clip from ant-man of the wasp but
that is a fight scene between the wasp
and ghost this is a really great scene
and it does an amazing job at showing
the ability for both suits the one that
Ghost has and the wasp so let's break it
down
dad are you seeing this Oh get out of
there
I gotta do something wait he's still a
work in progress
[Music]
the coolest thing to notice here is how
they fight it's super physical but
they're both so in tune with how their
suits work it's amazing the wasp using
her wings to attack going back and forth
between normal size and miniature size
attacking while miniaturized she seems a
lot more in sync with her suit than
ant-man and not to mention it seems like
she's a lot better at hand-to-hand
combat than ant-man is as well she seems
more intense and not too much in ghost
fighting skills she has the ability with
her suit to make herself and tangible
meaning she can pass through physical
objects or she can make it to where they
passed through her this is a pretty
killer ability to have while fighting
somebody and it's pretty apparent in
this movie clip demonstrated a few times
and one of those times is where the wasp
goes to shoot ghosts with her blaster
and ghost phases and makes it to where
it goes right through her but the best
and most awesome demonstration in this
clip is where ghost grabs and tackles
the wasp and throws them both at this
table and right before Ghost hits the
table she phases out goes through the
table which in turn makes the wasp hit
the table so ghost is definitely going
to be a hard villain to fight scene as
she has the ability to turn invisible
and become intangible but fortunately we
have two heroes in this movie as it's
titled ant-man and the wasp at the end
of this clip we see that dr. Hank Pym
gives Scott Lang the new and improved
ant-man suit judging by the end of the
scene dr. Hank Pym was not going to give
ant-man this new and improved suit but
seeing as how his daughter hope was in
trouble figured he'd give it to him so
there is the scene and a little
breakdown to go with it ant-man and the
wasp is only three days away and judging
by all the trailers we've seen and this
clip right here of this fight scene
between the wasp and ghost it looks like
it's going to be amazing let me know
what you think about this fight scene
between the loss and ghost let me know
your thoughts in the comments below and
of course be sure to like this video and
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on ant-man and the wasp
Avengers 4 and all things Marvel DC and
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you